the fighting around Bak mood is being
described as very tough and very painful
Ukrainian military officials and the
president say it's where the country's
future is being decided and Vladimir
zielinski's tone all but eliminate
speculation of a retreat
we need to destroy the enemy's military
might and we will
despite months of Fierce and bloody
combat that hasn't happened yet Russian
forces alongside private mercenary group
Wagner have been pushing to seize
control of the city it's a critical
Supply route to the contested East Rob
Hubert is a Canadian military analyst as
we see the fighting the fighting is
intense zielinski does not want to be
seen as showing his retreating on any
aspect because then it basically the
narrative that the Russians are able to
put forward is yeah you know we will
persevere one seventy thousand people
lived in buckmood in the Donetsk region
a Ukrainian salt mining town
nearly nothing is left yet the
bombardment of it and neighboring
communities is relentless
his mother and daughter from back moot
say they only know of a 90 year old man
and their neighbor trying to stick it
out they're on their way to crematorsk
with a few others they'll make the
hour-long drive but their destination is
not immune to the ravages of the war one
person was killed Tuesday in a Russian
missile strike on the city's center six
high-rise buildings were damaged and
several people injured the real moment
of achievement for Putin is when he is
able to convince enough of the major
decision makers within the West that the
war can't be won
combating that seed of Doubt is part of
the reason Ukrainian officials have been
front and center speaking with world
leaders the West has been unified to
this point and the donated weapons
flowing to Ukraine are the Difference
Maker Crystal gemancing Global News
London